how many NBA teams does California have
Kings slippers and Lakers Golden State
that's four four of them how many times
have all four California teams made the
NBA playoffs once only once last year
last year how many NBA championships do
the four California NBA teams have
combined oh 11 12 9 about 15 I think 25
oh how many titles have the Kings won
zero one in the 50s who is the King's
alltime leading scorer Chris Weber
that's Weber P I think that's fo Oscar
Robinson who is leading the kings in
total points scored this season uh foxes
that's Fox which player is leading
Golden State in assists and steals this
season oh Chris PA it's not Steph is it
who else I don't like the Warriors I
don't pay attention to the Warriors what
city is Golden State's g- League team in
I don't know this is it Seattle Cru what
city is Sacramento's g-league team based
in I don't know stock in g-league baby